دي اوامره من فريز ريال مدريد يطوي صفحتها
الى الابد معارك قضائيه تجمع بين محمد
صلاح وكريستيانو رونالدو
ساعدونا لنجدها كاف يبحث عن طفله جزائريه
على العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
الانباء حول رغبه ريال مدريد الاسباني
التعاقد مع كليانيكا في مهاجم باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي
له نشرت صحيفه ماركه الاسبانيه اليوم
تقريز اخر خلافاته الكثيره مع ناديه
الفرنسي وانه هنالك مخاوف بحسب المنشور من
اثاره اللاعب للازمات في صفوف ريال مدريد
بالاضافه لرغبه بابي في الحصول على
امتيازات كبيره وعدم صفاء الاجواء داخل
غرفه تغيير ملابس النادي الفرنسي المستحب
[موسيقى]
سيطرت حاله من الاستياء على عاده كبير من
رواد السوشيال ميديا هو تحديدا من قبل
مشجع الزمالك المصري بعد خساره الفريق
امام الاهلي بثلاثيه في الدوري المحلي
كان الفنان محمد هنيدي حيث السخيره من
الهزيمه بمشهد في فيلم فول الصين العظيم
قائلا اصلا بطوله الدوري مش مهمه واخدينها
مرتين وراء بعض احنا مركزين في دوري ابطال
افريقيا
ننتقل الى انجلترا حيث تورط عاده من
الرياضيين وعلى راسهم كريستيانو رونالدو
ومحمد صلاح في معارك قضائيه مؤخرا بسبب
مطعم ايطالي عالمي وبحسب التقرير الصحفيه
فان المطعم دخل في نزاع قانوني مع ثلاثه
مطاعم في انجلترا استطاعت جاني اكثر من
اربعه ملايين جنيه استرليني في العام
الواحد عبر استغلال اسمه من دون تصريحا
وتوافق العديد من الشخصيات البارزه عليه
من ابراجها محمد صلاح لاعب ليفربول لاعب
ليفربول الانجليزي وكريستيانو رونالدو
لاعب النصر السعودي
مدرب مانشستر يونايتد السابق الى جانب
الملاكم
الامريكي ولي
والى طفله جزائريه استطاعت خطف الاضواء
بعدما اطلق لاتحاد الافريقي لكره القدم
نداء للعثور عليها بعدما ظهرت خلال
المباراه التي جمعت المنتخب الكاميروني مع
نظيره الكونغولي في كاس امم افريقيا
للمحليين الكاف نشر عبر حسابه على تويتر
مقطع فيديو لرقصه الطفله واعلق عليها
اصدقاءنا في الجزائر نبحث عن هذه الطفله
الرائعه لدينا مفاجاه لها
ننتقل الى الرياض وتحديدا مع جورجينا
رودريغيز صديقه البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو التي اطلت في حفل جو اوتز بفستان
اسود وكالعاده هذه الاطلاله لم تكن لتمر
مرور الكرام رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعيه بسرعه انا ما شبه اطلالتها
بالنجمه مايا دياب مع اختلاف في خامه
القماش واخرون شبهوها ببلا حديد التي ظهرت
بفستان شبيه في حفل فاشن
لاطلالتها او العكس ولكنها بلا شك كانت
كذابه وغير عاديه
[موسيقى]